[Musique]
on a fait beaucoup d'auditions on a
évidemment auditionné ministre
évidemment
auditionné tous les services du buteur
le préfet le délégué général où une
manifestation enfin voilà on a eu
auditionné le maire de liverpool nous
nous sommes rendus au stade de france
pour échanger avec le consortium qui
gère le stade de france donc on a une
idée de ce qui s'est passé de manière
beaucoup plus précise et puis on apprend
à chaque fois un certain nombre
d'informations alors ce qu'on a appris
au stade de france hier c'est que les
caméras ont fonctionné sur le plan de
surveillance de sécurité n'ont pas à 14
heures mais à midi encore plus tôt et
que dès 14 heures il y avait des
mouvements il y avait il ya constatait
qu'il se passait des choses dès 14h à
19h par à 20h dès 14 heures donc voila
et puis on a appris qu'il y avait un
magistrat qui est passée qui était de
permanence on sait pas trop donc il y
avait quand même deux personnes qui
étaient censés pouvoir saisir les images
contenues ce qui s'est passé dans la
soirée voilà le magistral substitut de
permanence qui étaient là et le
commissaire de police le fils de police
qui étaient là donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous interroge beaucoup
pourquoi ne pas avoir saisi les images
en sept jours d'autant que le ministre
darmanin quand il est venu ici à 10 et
une mercredi de mémoire ne vous
inquiétez vannes a une âme un sénateur
des images on les a sauf qu'ils avaient
toujours pas saisi et qui ne les a
précisé dans les sept jours donc ça nous
intéresse beaucoup donc ça il faut qu'on
creuse pour qu'on puisse récupérer ces
images parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas
beaucoup de preuves on n'a pas de
preuves le mouvement de foule le nombre
réel de personnes dehors seules les
images prouvant la vérité voilà en tout
cas ce qu'on sait c'est que ça n'a pas
fonctionné et que cette communication du
gouvernement et en particulier du
ministre ne en un qui a simplement
twitté dès le départ que les anglais
étaient responsables de tout ben c'est
pas tout à fait ça c'est pas les anglais
qui sont responsables de tout je pense
qu'il ya dix services de l'état qui sont
responsables de ce qui s'est passé moi
ce qui me ce qui m'attriste profondément
c'est l'image de la france à
l'international
voilà le monde entier a vu une fille
asco français et moi ça ne me réjouit
pas
[Musique]
il ya deux choses qu'il faut dire c'est
que quand on écoute tout le monde tout
le monde a fait son boulot dans son coin
certes nous ne sommes pas responsables
parce que nous dans notre camp on a fait
notre boulot donc nous ne sommes pas
coupables mais s'il ya des coups bas il
va falloir qu'on les trouve c'est ça le
sujet voilà donc la cette impréparation
7,7 comment dirais-je cette inconscience
vis-à-vis de ce que nous allons gérer
mettre en place par exemple une
stratégie nouvelle de canalisation des
supporters sur un match aussi important
je suis pas sûr que ce soit très malin
mais ça on verra là le rapport le dira
et puis cette délinquance qui existe qui
est mobile qui vient que pour ça elles
existent d'abord la subit ailleurs que
dans le stade de france mais ça on ne
veut pas parce que vous avez j'ai eu des
propos nauséabonds selon le ministre de
l'intérieur quand j'ai osé parler de la
délinquance et quand j'ai osé parler de
son déni et des mots qu'ils
n'employaient pas pour poser les choses
mais ça c'est une réalité ce match on
est libre on est dans le déni et
l'omerta le problème c'est que le déni
ya rien de pire pour gouverner un pays
sûr si vous ne posez pas les problèmes
si vous ne les acceptez pas vous ne
peuvent pas les résoudre mais non on ne
veut pas parler de la délinquance alors
on dit 400-500 on sait pas trop de
personnes qui sont venues vouloir entrer
dans le stade à tout prix
voler les gens mais acceptons le c'est
une réalité c'est ce qui s'est passé
voilà ce match il a généré ça aussi
parce qu'on n'a pas su anticiper c'est
vraiment significatif d'un gouvernement
qui ne veut pas assumer ses
responsabilités mais il faut les assumer
un homme politique peut se tromper mais
il assume ses erreurs
[Musique]